okay
and we're live
so the thing about
the
whatever is
that is really complicated
um gme amc is doing pretty well nowadays
so congratulations to that company
gme was very very low and now it's
pretty
uh high on average
i don't buy any stocks because i'm not
good at that and i don't want to get
invested and
emotionally invested and all that
um so
what else is going on uh there's a a lot
of things going
on uh in the news
um
today was good i woke up and i did
uh 2000 words of writing
um
and
i hung out and had a good time
um
i ate dumplings
i had a good thanksgiving yesterday i
went over to my friend gareth's house
his family met his white family
had a good time try to convert some of
them to communism
um
they're just like i know you're trying
to do something new but have you ever
thought about not doing anything and
just not trying to do anything at all
and just leaving the way things are
everything's the way they are
uh thanksgiving was good
um then i came here
to my van and then i hung out with riley
and his crew and
watched lock stock in two smoking
barrels which was fun
but you know i'd rather have played
poker played catan i don't like just
watching things i think that's not that
fun
um
i
i love portland portland is a cool city
i would definitely go to portland um
i think portland is really fun
and
uh it's a great city i mean they
actually fight back against their police
which i respect
[Music]
is cool i've been there a lot i uh was
there
because i was in seattle i'd make little
trips down there sleep in my car and
hang out and sleep with other people
um
i think that
asians
are very very
large there's a lot of us
and it's really really cool
um
let me cook for you
yes my n word hans thank you reggie
tsunami hopefully you're black
uh portland is a really cool city and i
think that uh they're
really really strong in terms of
anger
um and i think that they are
living in a cool
environment chuck palahniuk on joe rogan
said that uh portland is like
still in the 90s it's like very 90s vibe
the vibes
so
um
let's see the news is
there's news going on today
some of the news going on is new variant
class
of concern and named omicron
this is the one from south africa
who meets for talks over the heavily
mutated variants as the uku
and others bring in travel bans
travel bans from where
to where or
what are you travel banning
south africa i think
the variant has been found in south
africa botswana and hong kong
and one case has been confirmed in
europe and belgium that's the thing
about letting a virus just evolve
inside your society is that it mutates
and becomes different it's not a good
strategy
we should
wear masks and try not to get out and do
as much as we can to not let it spread
but if we're not doing that then i'm
going out and
doing whatever i want because if i'm the
only one quarantining it does absolutely
nothing
so i picked the best state to be in if i
wanted to spread coronavirus it was
either texas or florida
that deserves it the most
and i think texas is like
openly flaunting it
and uh so i'm here in texas just doing
comedy like nothing is going on because
uh
i love comedy and it's like no one else
has taken it seriously
so that's why i'm here
to spread coronavirus
uh did you learn how to push sentences
out of your skull so slow how did you
learn to push your sentences out of your
skull so slow that's very visceral and
you know it's
interesting that you have a problem with
how slow i'm talking and not the content
of what i'm saying so i'll continue to
say [ __ ] up [ __ ] in a slow voice and
maybe
you'll not understand what i'm saying
and continue to let me
say [ __ ] up things about your country
um why do you have eyes underneath your
eyes
those are called bags
uh i got baggy eyes today
luckily i don't give a [ __ ] because i'm
not a
woman i'm a man who doesn't need to look
good
florida rocks the only thing we take
seriously is alligators
i'm here for the content um
so the new coronavirus variant is out
and it's just a matter of time before it
makes it here and before it spreads all
over america
um will i quarantine depends on how bad
it gets i might go into the desert again
just escape everything but i have this
huge opportunity with kill tony so
i might just keep doing that oh my
eyebrows my eyebrows are very high up on
my face
uh the distance between my eyes and my
eyebrows is very
big and it's been a source of concern
for me for a long time
uh thank you for noticing and pointing
it out
um but yeah i mean
what am i gonna do about my physical
body like this is how i was born and
this is how i am and it's like very very
cool to me because i got used to it
and it's like sort of cool that i can
do everything i do even with an ugly
face like it's like
carrying around a weight vest everywhere
you go so yeah you can do what you do
but have you tried doing it with small
eyes and very high eyebrows
it's more impressive that way anyone can
make it by being really
really uh
good looking but it's harder to do it if
you're
weird looking and so i consider it a
badge of pride that i can be so weird
looking
and still
do everything that i do so you know
go ahead and make fun of my physical
appearance
it's not a source of pride for me
it's not something that i uh
take value in and so
i mean
it's something that i tell myself every
day that i'm ugly so that if i do become
ugly or if i am ugly it's like
whatever not a big deal
small eyes big teeth
i'm like an asian character cringy
watching too much cats i don't
understand what's something you're
working on currently with your comedy
act
something i'm currently working on with
my comedy act is a joke about america
and coronavirus and how
uh
if we treated coronavirus like an
american like
guns and abortion and
uh credit cards hopefully it works i'm
gonna practice it before i do it
uh on kill tony ever i like to practice
a lot before i go and kill tony because
that's like a [ __ ] big audience and
it's there forever dog are you in the
van right now yes i'm always in the van
i'm in the van right now
i'm always doing these lives from the
van um
thoughts on youtube hiding dislikes now
i kind of wish i could see it but i
think it's good because it's just like
less negativity and you can't just be
like oh look at how many negative
things that this has
now you just have to like appreciate it
for the goodness of
the video that you're watching
um
so i like that
uh i don't think it's really necessary
to show the dislikes and it's just we're
just showing each other uh we're
adapting
to new ways of doing things and
social media is changing all the time
uh i heard you're a doctor and at navy
ceo what are you going to master after
comedy
um after comedy i would like to master
the art of
um
just meditating and not being like a
part of things like just
becoming one with whatever
so how i write a joke is like this tap
tap tap tap tap tap tap tap tap tap is
what it looks like
uh how i write a joke is i think about
something that's [ __ ] up or something
that i'm thinking about a lot like how
some people are just
um
they just adapt whatever viewpoint
exists in the world like oh this exists
let me be a part of that let me
uh because this viewpoint exists
let me adapt that into my way of
thinking because the fact that peop
other people are thinking it must mean
it's legitimate but not everything other
people think is
something that you should put into your
head and
make a part of yourself because there's
a lot of [ __ ] that we got to get rid of
before we move to the future and a lot
of people have backwards thoughts and
they're trying to make their animal
instincts
a more important part of themselves
because that's all they have and they
don't want to work hard at doing
something more than that
so they're like uh why don't we
have iphones but also
preserve my instinct to be uh
angry and violent and crazy and weird
and maybe we shouldn't
emphasize our animal instincts i mean if
they're good enough they'll survive on
their own we don't need to emphasize it
and if they're not good then we should
get rid of
so i just write jokes by like thinking
about things that i'm thinking about and
then
um
and then just writing it down and just
like figuring out what i'm thinking
about just whatever i don't try to like
oh you know would be so funny if there
was like a dog with a little butt on its
face and then like a little [ __ ]
on its ears and like a little poop poop
on its butt
it's like
why don't i just think about whatever
i'm thinking about and then make that
funny i don't like
break my brain trying to be humorous or
like
trying to just think of the craziest
thing ever
how did you find
how did you find what you enjoyed doing
what advice would you have for others to
find what they enjoy doing
i don't know if i'm fit to give this
advice but i think that if you want to
find what you enjoy doing
do things that humans are naturally
uh inclined to enjoy like
[ __ ]
skydiving or bungee jumping or whatever
you're attracted to
with your own individual personality
um
and then
if you find something you enjoy and that
you can get good at and it's like a
marketable skill and that's it's
important and if you're able to do it
then you should uh
then you should do it but there's like
things that humans have found enjoyable
and we know what those things are so
uh you should do that instead of like
trying to enjoy staring at
cryptocurrency or uh graphs of stock
markets like
do things that humans have actually
learned how to enjoy and is actually
a thing that people are able to enjoy
um and then do it and ignore the economy
because the economy will tell you and
force you to do things that are only
profitable for a certain
number of people
and
um
i'm going to turn it up a little bit
i want to get in the yellow do i want to
yell lower on the green
um yeah i mean the one percent controls
all the money so what the market decides
is whatever the one percent wants so
this is
uh so it's better to just do
whatever you actually want to do and
then find a way for the economy to work
for you instead of you working for the
economy
make the economy work for you find a way
to make the economy pay you for whatever
you actually enjoy doing there are
things that you enjoy doing enjoying
things is
a skill and
anyone can do it and we should all try
to be enjoying our lives instead of just
finding ways to make it work within
the economy because
economy is corrupt
you can't just follow money or else
you'll become an empty shallow person
it's just doing comedy for rich old
farts instead of saying anything real
just appeasing the one percent
did you always think you're funny i mean
i thought it was funny everyone thinks
they're funny
uh
alex had a great question
uh how do i find alex's question alex is
there a chance that jeremiah can come
back to kill tony i have no idea i'm
just a peon i'm like at the bottom of
the totem pole or the top whichever one
is the lowest position
um
when are you coming back to minnesota
uh coming to minnesota i have no idea
have you seen bo burnham's inside yes i
thought it was good i thought there was
a lot of good moments in there and a lot
of like not good moments
um
i think that uh there was a lot of stuff
that was like filler
but the good stuff was so good it was
like high highs
so it was worth it to sit through the
boring stuff what are your thoughts on
this coven 19 stuff
oh my gosh lex friedman
gave me 20 thank you mr lex friedman
uh amazing podcaster brilliant human
being and uh one of the
great voices of our time hans you're an
amazing comedian you've really enjoyed
the few times i saw you stand up here
and also keep in the great work
thank you mr lex friedman i love you
teddy grams you meet bears team bear
grams i uh enjoy teddy grahams i think
they're very tasty i eat them all the
time
uh and i'm happy to have them be part of
the whatever
i need to remember that people are
actually watching this [ __ ] uh
it's coronavirus i think uh we could
have handled it a lot better and i think
america has become sort of like a
breeding ground for coronavirus
but um i think that uh
it's difficult now like what do you do
now if it's already out like do you just
shut down forever or what
uh just out your front window
um
i am trying to maintain positive
energy
i don't know how to get this to be less
bright
this is out the front window there's my
van
steering wheel
oh my god
hopefully that's
shows you what i'm dealing with
um
hopefully it'll adjust
anyways
that's what's outside my front window
another person asking me are you high
i am not high
i wish i was i haven't been smoking a
lot i've been smoking a little bit but i
haven't been smoking a lot because my
throat is very sensitive and my throat
really gets sore even though i wish that
i could smoke more
um
smells like noodles and used fleshlights
i wish i love noodles and i love
fleshlights i've never actually had sex
with a fleshlight although i totally be
down for it it just seems like kind of a
crazy move to buy that for yourself it
seems very self-indulgent and i don't
think i deserve that much pleasure so i
never buy myself a flashlight
hans have you ever spoke with mike lair
he's is he a cool dude
yeah i've spoken with michael lair he's
very cool he's very nice and he's like
very very
uh
very um
you know like he's [ __ ]
he's like talking down to me and like
acting like he's gonna beat me up and
like
he's like uh
older than me and [ __ ] awesome and
stuff and it's pretty cool asians use
pot noodles instead of fleshlights high
maintenance from what i've heard
so left left laugh what up hans um
so yeah i mean
i love it here in austin this is a great
city i love the people here the people
here are nice and stuff hans when can we
expect swiggy back as soon as his name
gets pulled i'm sure he signs up every
week i see him all the time
um i mean that's the name of the game is
uh whatever
um as you put your name in the bucket
and hope to get pulled
or you just hope that uh
a member of your race tries to cancel
the
top young rising comedian in the world
and you get a free spot
on the podcast as a regular
um have you been to broward florida no i
don't think so
what's up
so what's up what with swiggy do we all
just imagine that set
that guy is crazy
he's got a lot of energy and uh some of
it's chaotic and some of it's
dangerous but most of it isn't so
hopefully he
does well and keeps succeeding he's a
very horny dude
um but yeah he's he's very funny and
he's got a lot of energy hopefully he
can harness it
so hans do you get any hate from the
asian community for doing the asian
jokes
i got one guy who's like a bodybuilder
who like was like you're selling out
you're an idiot i hate you
yes whatever whatever and i was like oh
[ __ ] you i'm like i hate asians i'll
[ __ ] all asians just to [ __ ] with them
um but it's like i uh
i i'm glad that uh i'm part of the asian
race because they can take it like if i
[ __ ] on asians so they can stand they
can stand it so it's like i can [ __ ] on
them all i want and asians will be
strong because i have confidence in my
uh people that they can take a joke and
that i won't hurt them like they're not
gonna be destroyed by me they're good at
ignoring things and
being stoic so yeah go ahead and be a
stoic asian i'm making fun of you learn
how to handle it that's what you do best
is take punishment as asians and
internalize it and then move on
uh so i don't uh really
try to baby or uh
you know
tiptoe around asian jokes it's just like
whatever if you're being if you're
offended by asian jokes then
you can go ahead and
be offended by asian jokes
because asians are strong and if you
think that
a comedian making asian jokes is going
to take asians down that means you have
less faith than asians than i do so
actually you're they racist against
asians i think asians are very strong
and i love asians and that's why i make
fun of them because i know they can take
it
hans i think if you identify as a woman
you can get a netflix special so easy
okay i mean i wouldn't do that because
then i'd have to uh you know be
inauthentic hans do you like freedom
freedom's okay
fem dumb
oh femdum do i like femdom i don't know
it depends on the woman a lot of women
are like think that they're good at
femdom but then it's like they're not
that good at femdom
they just like the idea of it
of control and power but then when they
actually get it they're not really good
at controlling and powering
uh and i'm not just talking about women
i'm talking about everyone is like that
like dudes that really want to dominate
a woman are probably not going to be
good at dominating people they just want
it so bad
uh when we can we expect a full special
build it and they will come
um i mean i would love to do an hour for
at least a year
over and over again go into comedy clubs
and perfect an hour and then record it
because just doing an hour and recording
it
isn't good enough i want it to be the
best hour and stuff
um so yeah i mean uh what else is new
fem dumb never heard of that pokemon
before uh yeah it's like freedom for
feminists it's called femdum i think
femdom would be nice um
please don't uh spam you know one
message at a time no copy pasting
why are crystalia brian kellen and bill
cosby your favorite comedian
you forgot louis ck
um they're my favorite comedians because
crystalia is very with it and very
internet savvy and very
cool and very uh he appeals to the young
children or he's trying to
i don't know
sitting next to me not paying attention
can you say hi to her hey anna
uh why don't you participate in your
life instead of just being on the phone
and
not being in the moment instead be with
your friend and connect with them
because being on the phone with someone
is like a 1 100th of being
in person with someone and if you can't
handle being in person with someone then
that's uh
sad and you'll never
be able to connect with anyone and
you'll need your phone to make half
connections instead of having a real
connection with people
so anna
pay attention
um
uh dominating on the court
so uh
any tips on living in a van the tip to
living in a van is uh you know don't
take yourself so seriously and you can
go through terrible things and
have terrible things happen to you and
it doesn't mean you're a bad person
don't take it so personally that you're
sitting in a bucket it doesn't mean
anything it's just the situation that
you're in you're not defined by the
situation that you're in
uh hopefully you define the situation
that you're in what poor girl is tied up
off screen hopefully anna if you're if
you need help if there's a crime
happening please dial 9-1-1 or
in the chat say
fallopian
robot
who's the old white guy sticker in the
top right corner of the screen all the
wall is that bernie that is bernie
i'm in a caravan what are you british in
a caravan
peeing in cups
um
living in a van just adopt to adapt to
the situation how does that play out
with ladies you have over with the
bucket
sich uh i could i just go into this room
right here
and then i pee
hopefully with the uh
blinds up with my visor sun visors up
um
i uh and then hopefully that doesn't
annoy them they can sort of hear it but
i uh i pee up there
uh girls can pee in a bucket i've been
told by female van life comedians they
just choose not to or something they
just
don't want to do survival things because
it's beneath them and it's kind of gross
especially with the whole vagina peeing
situation
so i mean the perfect girl would be a
girl who brings her own pee bottle to
sleep in the van
so if you're that lady
with your own pee bottle
call her at your boy
um
i think it's difficult with girls
if they're sleeping in the van because
after sexual and of course a lot of
ladies like to pee it out uh so that way
they can prevent urinary tract
infections so uh sometimes they pee
outside or if i'm in front of riley's
house to just go in riley's house and
use the bathroom
um but uh you know it's it's difficult
to pee in a van unless you're a dude in
which case it's really easy i uh
this
i have this little guy right here
it's almost a third full maybe a quarter
full
and i just put my little bpp in there
and i ppoa it's not that hard do you
think cosby hit the g spot uh
probably
uh what's your opinion on 23 gram theory
do you think cosby hit the g yes are you
coming to the east coast soon not any
plans
i wish i could get a club spot there so
i'm gonna try to
uh hit up clubs it's just such a pain in
the ass i have to [ __ ] do all this
work and like call people and then
advertise and it's like i wish i had an
agent who did it all for me but i i can
do it like i don't want to give 10 away
to some [ __ ]
because i can [ __ ]
uh
call people and do it on my own it's
just another barrier that i have to get
through have you ripped on the new
variant yet yeah i've been uh taking
lines of omicron
variant in the van i'm
i'm brewing up new variants as we speak
uh hey hans happy thanksgiving my name
is
um
i think that uh the new variant is
really cool and
it's great that we're just letting it
rip through the world and
hopefully it doesn't turn worse and
become vaccine resistant
[Music]
a mobile museum celebrates ugly and
iconic phones
france accuses uk pm of double talk over
migration
code ryan's we need the cocaine
collectors retrieving smuggled drugs
uh
i think that it's awesome that
the ccp is
there threatening everyone
with death
i wish that the ccp could get their [ __ ]
together so they could provide an
alternative vision for the world but
unfortunately they're very
much focused on just barely making it
and trying to survive and beat america
and they're not actually providing
uh an alternative to what we have
they're just
a more repressive version of the same
thing
and we should
uh
fix things
um
so i'm not buying any crypto i don't
think it's worth it i think it's a
difficult thing to get good at and it's
not worth getting good at
uh crypto is it'd be cool to get i just
think that the value of crypto is more
than just in
uh buying it and holding on to it i
think actually using crypto would be the
way to go it's just once we can do that
that'd be awesome
um so
uh
is this van studio
yeah this is
the van land
van
the man with the van
what's your best advice for someone
doing stand-up for the first time
my best advice
would be
to
connect with the audience look them in
the eye and tell your joke like you're
telling it to people
and
have like a joke uh have a
have a goddamn uh setup and punchline
and uh try to make it funny funny over
everything uh make it funny first don't
try to go for the craziest subjects
possible a lot of people when they start
out comedy they go for like rape jokes
and holocaust jokes and like
uh [ __ ] donkeys jokes and it's just
like go for the stuff that is uh
better to do and more easier to make
people laugh like talk about yourself
and like i would say be self-deprecating
in the beginning some people are too
self-deprecating but if you're not
self-deprecating enough it's
not pleasant because then it's like oh
do you have any idea who you are who you
are
when someone hands me a flyer it's like
they're saying here you throw this away
mitch hedberg joke very funny thank you
for putting that in there
um
what i learned eating at 8 000 chinese
restaurants what they all taste the same
that they are just
uh
chicken nuggets covered in different
sauces
that's uh paul
some things joke
paul brock cow or something from seattle
um
i have met mark normand i told him that
i had a joke similar to his joke that i
did and for him to not do it on this
show that i was on and i felt
really bad that that was how he was
meeting me but i didn't want him to say
the joke again because then it's like oh
it's the same joke and the audience
wouldn't like it so
i wanted him to
not uh
no do a bad
uh
have a bad set so i told him that i did
a joke similar to one of his jokes
uh it's the joke that's like uh
my friends like i suck to be gay because
if you're gay most of the gender that
you're attracted to isn't even attracted
to you back and i was like whoa i can't
even imagine they must masturbate a lot
so that's the joke
who's the biggest hack you met
probably uh
i don't know i don't want to think about
that uh the funniest person i met is
probably casey rocket or
gabriel rutledge or
um
devin for real and olympia
and all that brett fleiberg
people i came up with william montgomery
um
i uh i think it's funny that swiggy so
is great why is brendan's shop
considered a comedian because he does
comedy mike norman is killing it right
now rogan is cool in person yes yes very
cool amazing cool alpha male
daddy
uh
male role model cool cool person
i don't have
arm hairs that makes me uncomfortable
when women have more than me
i mean it should make them uncomfortable
you should be fine you should be like
look at this hairy armed
person
but you know you can always shave
um
oh thank you
[Music]
leon greetings from sydney we have a
great comedy culture in australia come
entertain us i'd love to there's so many
great comedians in australia
there is uh arge barker who's an
american who does one well there
um there is
that really nerdy asian guy who's super
funny
uh he's like doing meta comedy very very
funny people
um
[Music]
stormy is doing well she recently did a
ask me anything type thing on her
instagram and
someone asked about me and she was like
oh yeah
the the question was are you still
friends with hans
and kim and then she was like yeah bff's
forever and then i was like happy to be
best friend zoned
uh
and it was a hilarious moment shared by
all what can you do what kind of can do
you have
from the windows to the walls so um
i haven't shaved
uh this is my face uh
it's only like two three days worth and
it's not that much i feel like my
facial hair is sort of uh becoming less
pursuit
uh
but i'm more hairy than i was a long
time ago
don't you ever get scared in your van if
someone will break in and murder you i
mean not really what do i have what i'm
afraid of is
people
uh crashing into me
how did you like the new york scene when
you were there i loved it i mean it
wasn't the best in terms of being nice
and friendly and
fostering talent and making sure that uh
you're getting the best comedy but i
think it was a great place to be because
there's so many great comedians there
amazing comedians some of the best open
mics in the world
the best open mics in the world happen
in new york city the best shows happen
there in new york city it's just such an
amazing place what i didn't like was
that no one really
uh
was going to care about you even if like
you are good like they're gonna make it
as difficult as possible like my friend
raul is super talented and
no one gave a [ __ ] about uh
helping him and
giving him an outlet
and i think that's [ __ ] up i think new
york is like arrogant they think they're
better than everyone and they don't need
uh anyone to
uh help them so they just don't try to
help others even though it's
in their best interest to have a better
comedy scene so people are just killing
in obscurity there and it's uh
ridiculous and it's like they act like
they're better than people when they're
not and it's mostly about
uh schmoozing and favoritism and
[ __ ] did you go to high school in
the states and if you did were you
popular because you were funny uh i want
to say i was popular i would say i was
average i was like not too popular but
not too unpopular i
would i did a speech at the end of my
senior year where i was like if you have
a crush on someone you should tell them
because i had a crush on someone all
throughout middle school and high school
and
never really happened with me and julia
breslin uh
it's i think like i was too nervous and
shy and i was also arrogant i was just
like i don't want to get rejected so
i'll never talk to her ever
so i shouldn't i should have done
something
uh you should make your goal to smash
kim kong
and then get a show on gaston okay i
mean i don't think kim kongden wants to
smash me um
if she does then obviously
i'd be down for that but i think that uh
she has bigger fish to fry and uh bigger
dicks
uh than mine
that she has access to so uh i don't
know how much i could really offer her
but i if i uh if i could date her i
would probably date her who wants to
spoon hans online it's crazy because
it's like i would date anyone i like i'm
don't mean to be such a [ __ ] but um
i could find a way to be with anyone
it's just like we just have to find
someone who says yes and then i'll like
dedicate my life to someone and it's
like sort of pathetic that it's so easy
for anyone to have me but you know
it's also a good thing because i am free
for love i'm able to love i let love
flow through me and i can really hang
out with anyone but it's hard to
find someone who you can hang out with
long term because in the long term your
real self comes out
would you prefer to date a woman who is
as funny as you but doesn't like all
your jokes or date a woman who just
finds you really funny but isn't as
funny as you
uh
um i think that uh both are legitimate
strategies i don't want someone who's
just
uh weak and just like likes me and
there's nothing else but also
like if that's where they're at then
like i love them for that too i don't
know dude
honey
i want someone who's funny but like
isn't too enamored with their own humor
like it's okay if you're funnier than me
but i just want my ability to say my
jokes and like
if someone is is funny and they think
they're funny then they just talk the
whole time they're just like ahaha
that's so funny and then here's another
thing and another thing another thing
and then i'm just like silent and then i
can't really talk or have an opinion or
be a part of the relationship it's just
me watching that person but if we back
have a back and forth uh
i think a 50 50 would be perfect and i
think that's what we should strive for
you know you should shut up half the
time and you should be talking half the
time
uh that would be awesome
biggest turn off
i would say biggest turn off is people
who cannot be a part of something larger
than themselves who are always thinking
about themselves who are like oh you're
ruining my vibes right now so enough of
you
bye
and it's like it's not about your vibes
it's about our vibes and if you're only
thinking about your vibes then we can't
create a beautiful thing together it's
only about you and then
it's like oh this is how you make me
feel well how about how you make me feel
and how about how we feel overall
together and it's like people
who can't really
share or be a part of something together
they only have to be by themselves
because
they uh
they can only think about one person at
a time
um
i uh yet to remind a lady of their
father a
i mean some people grew up with asian
fathers
where is the post office bernie sanders
sticker in the back hell yeah it's right
there do you believe in astrological
signs no i do not believe in
astrological signs that is not in any
way to make a
uh
judgment about people and
uh
you know
it's not it's not a scientific way to
determine how many personalities exist
uh it's just like uh you can do that
with anything like just empty
whatever's and just have random
personality traits assigned to it it's
it's just it they they admit that it's
[ __ ] it's just like if you want
[ __ ] then that your mind can latch
on to that i just don't think it's
uh a good way to do things is
astrological signs uh it's like people
who are not smart enough to judge people
on their own they need like another
thing like oh you're i need you to know
if you're a [ __ ] whatever to know if
i should like you or not you're just
supposed to figure that out on your own
you're supposed to be like oh i like
this person
because they're like this and this and
they're introverted and they're smart
and they're with it
um you can have a telegram uh but yeah i
mean you should be able to figure it out
on your own you shouldn't need
astrological signs to judge people it's
hard to judge people and it's hard to
have like a good read on people but you
should try you shouldn't just give up
and completely rely on [ __ ] stars to
help you figure out what people are like
uh how much korean can you speak now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
can you explain your fingering technique
i mean it seems like girls like this
i start with one finger
this finger's kind of broken for me
right now
but i start with one finger
and then i put in two fingers after the
one finger and then
do the scrape the top
uh yeah i wish i could do that to people
i don't even need to have sex with
people i just want to make them feel
good like
through their genitals it's just like so
awesome because
it's like so personal
um
i just uh think that it's vulnerable and
like i want to make people feel good and
like people don't want me to make them
feel good unless like i do
yeah don't scrape
i don't know i don't know what that's
called thud tap it
i mean you got to get that resonant
frequency so that
when you like thud are like
when you uh
finger them then it's like [ __ ]
it reverberates and then the
reverberations match up with like how
you're [ __ ] and then when when when
you get that [ __ ] when they're the
the [ __ ] walls are echoing and then
you're making it echo more and more
because you're [ __ ]
studying at the right time it's like
swinging on a swing you gotta get all
those uh spasmic muscle walls in the
vagina to be
uh
reverberating like a
timpani drum
um but uh it's like there's so many
requirements so this is like a joke that
i'm working on but it's like you have to
be like this and that and that and you
gotta have like nice hair and it's like
really just too much on your box
like i feel like i can do that
i feel like anyone can do that like
why are you like having so many uh
requirements for people to touch your
genitals like your genitals are
ridiculous they're just stupid little
things down there like you shouldn't be
like only certain people can touch my
genitals only the best people can touch
my genitals because that's how awesome
of a person i am i only have the best
people touch my genitals
it's like if you're such a you know
uh
snob about who touches your genitals
you're probably not that
easy to make come you're probably like
really
into yourself and really arrogant and
[ __ ]
uh so i think like uh genitals should be
uh for everyone and like uh
you shouldn't uh be so stingy with your
genitals but uh i mean i understand like
if you're being
propositioned all the time you need some
sort
of uh
metric to
prevent uh
just being hounded over your genitals
but then if more people were open with
their genitals then there'd be less
desperation and panic
over genitals and then we could have
more functional society
receiving transmission
it's a starcraft thing
[Music]
tony will demolish do you ever play dnd
no
uh
everyone liked the stream hanzo loves
your new joke by the way trap concert
thank you
uh stay tuned i got more coming on kill
tony
everything's two weeks back
i wish it was live again i love live
killed tony
um
check out steve martin's book on comedy
uh that's a good book hey hans kim have
you ever had stage fright yes or if
you're public speaking yes hans kim is
so korean he referenced starcraft and
their goose children
i love starcraft 2. hans king with miss
pat would be great
thank you
um so yeah i mean
it's just crazy uh
that uh
uh
the comedy is happening and
um i think that we should be having more
sex and i wish
that girls would have more sex with me
uh i think that the coronavirus is sad i
wish americans were better at working
together as a group
i heard the seating of vulcans is not
good
volkam
some of the seats are good uh if you're
in the back then you're staring at a tv
which is not that good but it's cool to
be in that room and feeling that energy
um so another thing that's really funny
about the world is that uh
there's a lot of uh
mutations to the current ovaries kurdish
women's first chanel vic channel victim
to be named
was it
northern okay
iraq is sad amazon uh they're doing a
boycott of that um
so that's cool that's i heard it on
reddit do you have a custom keyboard no
it's just a normal uh mechanical
keyboard that i got for
starcraft um
i would love to get a job as a cruise
ship comic
but then i want to be able to do kill
tony
i'd rather be a kill tony comic than a
cruise ship comic on the hierarchy i
think kill tony comics are better than
cruise ship comics
can you tell us anything about rogan's
new club i can tell you that uh it's
gonna be top of the line they're gonna
have the best everything in there i can
tell you
uh
that it's gonna be dope i can't tell you
anything more than that or else i'll get
in trouble
uh how do we get more comedy and sex
into society
um i think the boomers have to die out
and their sex shaming has to die out and
i think that we need to
be uh embracing a polyamory and not be
stuck to victorian era sex standards of
like oh i'm your man and you're my woman
and i will give you all my inheritance
and here is your job you are
going to
be a broodmare and pop out children and
well i'll go to work and
make money polluting the rainforest so
that my children can have a nice life
are you opening for you are opening for
oregon i think that is better than
cruise ships definitely
uh you need a podcast with rogan yeah
let me just call him up right now and
start a podcast with joe rogan the
busiest comedian in the world i'm
guessing kill tony will be at rogan's
club when it opens hopefully at least i
hope so too i have no information i have
no idea
i think we're still going to do shows at
vulcan because vulcan is dope and
they've been super supportive to us
and the people there are super really
dope
is william montgomery always pissed
william montgomery is the nicest person
uh i don't want to uh
ruin the key fade but he is so dope and
i really love him and i hope he loves me
and it's just like i uh i really like
hanging out with him he's the regular
that i hang out with the most so it's
really cool
thanks for your comedy man i've enjoyed
it all thank you secret clown
will you have a parking spot at joe's
club
um i don't know if i should say this but
i'm hoping for a parking spot at joe
rogan's gym so that i can shower and
work out there and get joe rogan buff
and i can practice my arm bars on his
dummies and
just have an awesome awesome life so if
i could park at as gym that'd be dope uh
his club would be dope too but i don't
think they'll have showers
uh hey will you kick me out of your chat
sure
um you're in the best place
you're killing yeah thank you i mean we
are in the best place for comedy right
now austin texas baby this is where it's
gonna be free from any corporate uh
meddling and interference this is just
purely an artist community this is just
comedians doing comedy for no reason
other than to be better at comedy
hans why are you when are you when you
touring with william we should talk
about that i'm going to talk with
william and hopefully we'll tour when
can we expect your one hour special like
the video
like the video please and subscribe um
when are you touring with william that'd
be dope to tour with william uh that'd
be a great show how short are david
lucas legs
um i would love to work out at joe
rogan's gym i'm a little
skinny right now so i want to get buff
being buff is good for your health
lifting heavy weights stacking plates
and destroying these wannabe
soy boys is good for your health i got
to be able to crush my enemies and
hopefully with joe rogan's new club i'll
be able to do that do you believe in
aliens
i don't believe in aliens i think that
aliens um
you know either they're too good for us
or that they don't exist or worse
technologically more advanced than them
maybe it's really hard to get sentience
and most of them are just scrounging
around eating bacteria
but higher cam angle is the move oh
really oh [ __ ] you want a higher camera
angle
okay
you know that's possible i can do that
um i think it's really awesome that uh
i can have this podcast with just chat
maybe i'll be taking phone calls if you
would like to call in please let me know
uh
and uh you know maybe i could have like
a podcast that's [ __ ]
awesome and [ __ ]
um i think it's really cool that uh
we can do this with technology
um i hope to
be
better and successful and stuff
california is a hell hole everyone's
leaving not going i would love to visit
california i'd love to go to la um the
only reason i'm here is because i hate
uh invest in entrenched power structures
and this is a new power structure
i think here that you can grow up
beautiful in the sunlight uh full of
happiness and
joy and in california or new york you're
growing up in the shade full of angry
depressed people and stuff like that
so
i think it's better to be
out and about
in austin because austin is like full of
real people
uh
and we should strive to be
real we don't need to
have
be invested in the old power structures
because that's just
used to [ __ ] with people and make sure
that they're not going to stage a
revolution and change
the way things are and
i think it's better to change the way
things are
i uh
i think it's great that
joe rogan let me open for him
really cool
is this too high
hopefully that's good enough
hopefully it focuses
but yeah i like the higher camera angle
too uh
this is a lot like how hassanabe does it
so he's also one of my heroes
asanabi
i would love to be
a guest on whatever he's doing
whatever that might be
but uh yeah i like this a lot better
thank you for the suggestion see i'm
open to change
uh do aliens exist i mean
what are we gonna do about it
hans you're doing it i watch all the
thank you man thank you bobby norman i'm
brad how tall is rogan is he a dwarf i
mean
he's uh
he's as tall as you think he'd be
um but i uh
i think that he is very physically
threatening not because of his height
but because of his width
uh he's more of a width
he's very witty
he's with it
um
is this the inside of the van yes this
is inside of the van do more of these
man i'm sharing you all over thank you
sacred clown hans are you only comedian
out of your siblings
are you are you only comedian out of
your siblings
yes i am only comedian of sibling maybe
i'll be like the reagan reagan family
and all my [ __ ] whatevers will have
a goddamn thing he's not that short joe
rogan isn't
uh have you had any joe rogan elk i wish
i wish i had joe rogan elk no i'm not
gonna ask joe rogan for elk he
is a busy man and
if everyone asked him for elk then the
world would be
very sad because he everyone would only
appreciate him for his elks
elk i appreciate uh joe rogan for
something more than just elk and that is
his wisdom and his energy and i just try
to soak it in as much as possible
someone said lower the angle
i hope this is what they meant
because this is a tripod i can't really
get it lower
um
and it's on my bed and it's like this
whole thing maybe i could figure it out
but maybe later this is in the middle of
the stream so i'm not going to do it
what does your average day look like
good question
straight line smiley face
my day looks like this i wake up at
about noon maybe 2 p.m and then i brush
my teeth i lay in bed i answer my
messages i jerk off
and i look at instagram look at all my
notifications
uh
and then i
uh
and then i [ __ ]
write 2 000 words this is an ideal day i
don't always write 2 000 words every day
but ideally i would write 2 000 words
every day
and then uh
after i do that i uh
brush my teeth and then i started
streaming a lot uh i like streaming it's
like a podcast except i'm the only one
doing it and i just love doing it alone
because
it's like i get to talk as much as i
want like a hundred percent of it is
just me talking like in a normal podcast
with other people i'm only 50 of the
conversation
uh so this is like doing two of those
podcasts
at the same time but it's like i do love
bouncing ideas off other people it's
just like i gotta find the right person
and i don't agree with a lot of people
and it's like i gotta get them on my
schedule like we have to like match your
schedules and it's just like a pain in
the ass to do
um
but yeah yeah that's my normal day and
then after i stream after i write two
thousand words i lay down and write two
thousand words staring up at my little
thing
uh and then after that i eat and then i
try to stream this is my ideal schedule
and then i go do mike slash shows so and
then i start at six until like
midnight and then i come back i
watch some succession i wish tony
hinchcliffe recommended and that i
started watching
i uh chill out i eat teddy grams i
probably ate something on the road
uh it's just like
that's just pretty much my schedule
uh
and i enjoy it
um but yeah i mean what else is new
you fixed that trap concert joke yet uh
sure
it's just such a hard joke to do now
because that
that story went away quick so i'm glad
that i got it recorded
dd shows every day er day sun except
yesterday when it was uh not a
show day was thanksgiving
um i was also jealous of myself of that
one stripper i think you mean stormy
daniels and then there's
another stripper rosalie
sexually they're very very attractive
and i'm very attracted to them
and it's amazing that i got to kiss
strippers because most people never get
to chris strippers they hate it when you
kiss them but
they came up on stage and it was a show
and they they're used to the stage and
being sexual on stage and it's just it
was just a great time
fat bong rip or shot gonna be your fat
bong rip please it [ __ ] me up more i
have a good time
things are good
i love piping uh it just feels good on
my long long [ __ ] letting
your favorite brazilian comedian
i won't ruin this joke but he is a great
brazilian comedian yeah most of us guys
are envious but happy for you lol it's
such a weird thing getting to kiss all
those girls because it's like
what do people actually want
do they enjoy
watching me kiss people are they
thinking that they're me
are they uh i don't know is is
interesting
a lot of people didn't like it and now
they have to not like me just for who i
am because i stopped kissing chicks so
they just have to admit like oh we just
don't [ __ ] like you and that's gonna
happen i can't do anything about that so
it's like
turns out you didn't hate me kissing
strippers you just hated me
ha ha
joke's on you
you thought you were like disliking me
for other reasons but i knew the real
reason you didn't like me
uh but that small amount of people a lot
of people enjoyed it and a lot of people
uh
enjoy it when i post about it as
christina p says i can watch you do that
all day
she did say something like that
um yeah i mean it's just like a good
thing to do like kissing people we
should be kissing people more and i'm
glad that i could spread kisses around
the world
and then i could like get better at
kissing people and learn
what what girls want
what girls want is to be smooched on
kill tony that's what i've learned
uh
take it from me an expert on women women
just want to be on stage kissing an
asian face
uh does it get hot as [ __ ] in that van
or what yeah that's what this thing is
for i got a little ac it's hooked up to
power shore power
so i do that whenever i have to
um
yeah it's pretty [ __ ] dope
um
does it get hot as [ __ ]
how do you write jokes like this
right now i'm writing a joke
i write a joke by thinking of something
that i want to think about and then i
try to make it funny um
you know
like i like thinking about how to make
this whole thing that we're living in
better instead of just like myself how
to make myself better i'd want everyone
to get better and it'd be easier for me
to get better because we're playing a
game that everyone can succeed at if i'm
just playing a game that's already
[ __ ] up and i make it only better for
myself not only is that easier it's not
as satisfying i'd rather play a game and
make it better for everyone and not just
myself how much does that ac unit cost
on amazon i think it was like 400 bucks
or 500 bucks or 300 bucks or 200 bucks
it costs money
and i knew that i needed it and so i
used it and it saved my life this thing
this thing is a lifesaver it makes this
place [ __ ] livable and not a [ __ ]
swamp
so i love it i love my ac but i'm not
going to need it anymore it's [ __ ] 40
50 degrees here now so i'm going to stow
it away and then live my life
i'm graduating law school in canada
should i pick up and move to austin
without finding a job
how much money do you have in the bank
account what do you want to do here
uh
what are you going to do
with your life and how are you going to
do it
i don't know your life if i were you and
i were in canada
first i'd like try to get a visa or
something to america because i don't
know how that works and then i would uh
do stand-up comedy and do it forever and
approach it like an asian approaches
violin
[Music]
if you are an asian doing violin you
practice every day you try to get better
you do shows as much as you can you
listen to the best violin player do it
do it like it's violent so many people
are like oh man i'm gonna get a special
in six months and then i'm gonna [ __ ]
uh
shake hands with all the famous people
but if you're learning how to play
guitar you wouldn't be like yeah i'm
just gonna learn how to play guitar in
six months and then i'm gonna be famous
like people think comedy is just you
going up on stage and being yourself and
it's like you have to be a better
version of yourself
oh no visa necessary for canadians come
on down garinder
practice law and in debt
and punjabi so kind of asian yes i mean
if you want to do comedy
or whatever you want to do
austin's a great place to do comedy
that's why i would move down to austin
if you're into comedy but if you're not
into comedy i don't know what you want
to do if you want to do [ __ ] silicon
valley [ __ ] go to san francisco
so be forced by your parents lol it'd be
great if people were forced by their
parents to do comedy maybe the world be
a funnier place why do people online
have big professional microphones and
their audio is crappy low and distorted
shaking my head are you talking about me
is my audio low distorted and shitty oh
my god just walk across the border like
everyone else yeah just go to mexico and
join the throngs of people that are
risking their life to come over here
i'm not hunting for an apartment right
now if an apartment comes to me i'll
live in it uh if i can make my enough
money through youtube that's a reliable
source of money then i'll do it also if
i'm touring then i won't need a [ __ ]
apartment i'll have this van so it's
like
i don't know
audio is good sounds good yeah [ __ ]
whatever guyana spice [ __ ] brazilian
[ __ ]
uh
south american country punjabi florida
probably has
lots of law jobs
can i name a wee strain after you call
it hans van stink thank you please do i
would love for people to smoke my van
stink
uh
okay if i had an only fans
i
uh
uh
i don't know what a cloud lifter is i
mean i'll get a cloud lifter since
everyone has one i'm gonna ask red band
what a cloud lifter does
but it's like i already have this
microphone why don't they build a cloud
lifter into this microphone just like
put it right here
like what the [ __ ] why do i have to buy
another thing it's annoying
uh what was i talking about
um
hans would you ever get a pet dog that
you aren't compelled to eat i used to
have a dog and i wasn't eating it oh
only fans if i had an only fans that'd
be [ __ ] dope i could have sex with
strippers and recorded and put it online
i just don't know if i want videos of me
having sex
online i don't know what the
implications of that are and how people
are going to treat me and stuff
it cleans up the low end
okay why doesn't it do that
automatically why can't i get like a
little computer program that does that
um
if you look at my facebook i made a
little thing that looks like only fans
except it says only hands only hans
patreon before only fans bro please
patreon me i'm on patreon if you want a
patreon me they take like eight percent
so just venmo me if you want
what does red band smell like he smells
like pepperoni pizza dude
what do you mean what does he smell like
he smells wonderful he's a very clean
man he's a rich rich man no korean
dramas on tonight he know king's
affection drama until the time tonight
um i
i i love red band he's so nice he just
texted me the lineup for the secret show
tonight so come out if you're in austin
to the secret show thursdays and then i
have my show
uh other people which is like a dating
show
uh
you know on sundays at 6 p.m at creek in
the cave so come out to that
those are always fun
um i went to georgia tech um i had a
good time there redband smells like
money and pepperoni
i was just kidding about the pepperoni
please don't uh cancel me please don't
hack me red band
where do most of your jokes come from
from my mouth most of my jokes come from
i mean you hear them right
uh they're just like about dating and
women and how they should [ __ ] more or
how like being a man and being uh
an individual is like lonely and how
it's like i'm from my perspective i'm
awesome but then that's everyone's
perspective
how do i make most of my money i used to
make most of my money through
unemployment uh during the pandemic
pandemic unemployment assistance pua and
then i have food stamps now i have uh
youtube money
it hasn't come in yet but it says that
they're going to give me like 800 bucks
so i can't wait for that
and then
i do shows and joe rogan pays me a lot
of money and tony pays me a lot of money
to open for him and
i do
shows uh like at the creek in the cave i
get 50 of the door
and i do stand-up shows in
like up up north at dallas comedy club
that paid me
um
i uh
[Music]
i think that
it's crazy if you want to make it in
comedy
here's what i would do i would approach
it like it's violin like i said practice
a lot do it a lot every day practice all
the time the more you practice the
better you're gonna get
uh the more you practice the better
you're gonna be than other people who
don't practice
[Music]
and then
practice every day and then
just be dedicated
to your craft and love it and live for
it
like chuck palahniuk lives to write
that's his discipline i think people
are
tools
tools are not meant to be comforted and
you know laid in a soft bed of roses and
pampered and tools are meant to be used
if you're not being used you're not an
effective human you're if you're not
doing anything if you're just trying to
be comfortable that's not
you're not being the fullest version of
yourself if you don't actually do
something with your life then your life
is wasted life is not about just seeking
comfort and being the most comfortable
possible it's about doing the most
damage and putting yourself out there
and like doing a lot of [ __ ]
and the more [ __ ] you do the better it
is
uh
i don't actually write
um
uh physically i write um
on a computer i just don't write
physically it's just too inefficient
and i mean if you get used to writing
then it can be a beautiful thing do i
have disney plus yes my friend gave me a
disney plus account
i'm telling my wife she's a tool i mean
i don't know why he did that i'm not
encouraging that
i think your wife could be a tool but
that doesn't have anything to do with
anything
uh what's your favorite fast food panda
express do you floss regularly no i
should though
thank you m933 is talking to my
grandmother and are being confused
between me saying horror movies and
horror movie a good premise for a joke
yeah i mean depends on how good your
grandmother voices and if you can be
like why are you watching a horror movie
back in my day that was only for the
meditative
i didn't want you watching a horn maybe
and you're like come on grandma we're
all watching it let's go watch a horror
movie i mean it might make you all
bloody and there's a lot of blood in it
then why are you watching a horn movie
with so much blood in it oh my grandma
all the best horror movies have blood in
it and there's also like a saw and like
i don't know
on and on
make it a funny that uh
horror movie like a funny thing to be in
a horror movie what's something that's
normal in a horror movie that would be
horrible in a horror movie
um but yeah just
do that and that's a good joke if you
can make it a good
joke how do i deal with the existential
crisis of life by trying to live my life
for other people and
um
trying to uh
find purpose and uh like if this world
is all that we have then the whole
purpose of it is other people you know
like if
if we're here even if this is a
simulation uh
you should be
like oh let me try to do the best in the
simulation how do you do good in the
simulation how do you get in the
simulation by making it good for other
people so that if they're in the
simulation at least they're having a
better life and i think that's like
ideal that's something that would be
awesome to do
puerto rican
um
and so like if you're here on this earth
then only our only purpose should be to
make it better for other people and if
you're just in it for yourself then it's
like a shitty shitty stimulation it's
like
not that fulfilling just to be
trying to do the best and make the most
money and have the most comfort and
pleasure i think there's
more to it than that
if it's a simulation why don't you make
it a bigger van
manager make it with a bigger van
because this is the perfect size i don't
need it to be bigger it'd be nice i
guess if it was bigger but most of the
time i'm laying down or sitting here
so i mean how much would it really help
to have it bigger then it'd just be more
things to air condition or more space to
heat up
this is perfect
this is even
bigger than most people's van life so
i'm fine with it
um
i really like
doing podcasts because it's like
comedians are
[Music]
good at podcasts i mean not me but
comedians are because they're
trying to be good people they're talking
when you're talking you're just
displaying who you are as a person
uh i think people have a really finely
tuned [ __ ] sensor that's what most
of our evolutionary social intelligence
is for is for finding out about other
people so if i'm on stage performing
then i'm gonna have to be good at
uh being a good person either i could
get good at lying and pretending i'm a
good person or i could get good at
actually being a good person lying to
pretend that you're a good person is so
much more work than actually just being
a good person and lying to pretend to be
a good person it doesn't make you happy
or fulfilled or fill you with good
emotions and it leads to bad
[ __ ] overall
audio is low
let's turn it up
uh and uh actually being a good person
feels better makes you a better person
and it's like [ __ ] awesome
uh you say do what pleases you yet
you're a comedian pleasing others plea
pleases me to please others that's why i
want to finger people
um i don't even need to have sex with
people i just want to
uh make them feel good like i don't even
need to come
i want
if i could i would just like to make
other people come
this is like an anti set all hecklers in
no direction lol yeah okay whatever
who cares about morals and comedy it's
comedy i mean at some point you're
displaying some sort of morality
um so you might as well talk about the
good stuff
i mean uh
there is an art to not having morality
and it's like how you choose and where
you choose to not have morality
um
so
i think it's like a little bit of both
i i don't even know what i want with sex
it's like if i'm just doing it for other
people's pleasure like
what do i want out of it if i i don't
know
i don't know who i am and what i'm doing
and where i'm going
um
where do you park chison your van
i park chisong my van wherever i please
uh [ __ ]
uh whatever in a park
in a parking lot near a walmart anywhere
really
i uh i think if you're doing comedy that
uh it's important to
do a lot of it and get good at it
like violin
um i with sex i just want to have a lot
of it and like connect with people
and it's like instead of like just being
with people uh in their logical self you
get to tap into their animal selves and
just be animals with them and that's
like so much better and like we need
that we can't just always be in our
heads
we need some uh release from that and to
like actually
be uh
[ __ ] people and being animals instead
of like isn't it cool that we have like
a button on our body that if you press
it just doesn't matter how smart you are
you just turn into an animal you can
just like jerk them off and it's like
uh equals mc square and you start
jerking off and like
like it's cool that we have that button
and we should press it more instead of
just like always being in our heads and
always being logical then if you are
having that but press then you're a
better logical person because you're not
always trying to suppress your animal
desires or getting that released a lot
and i think that
the fact that we don't do that enough is
bad and that we're always stuck in one
mode if you have a different variety of
modes you exist and then it's better
uh cops don't harass me for living in a
van although it's difficult in texas
it's way more difficult in texas than
any other state i mean california is
pretty difficult too because everyone
does it i've never had to fight off
intruders there's one guy i parked in
front of his house he came out with a
flashlight and shined it did a 360
around my van and that was infuriating i
know where he lives now i don't know why
he would do that i know where you live
he just [ __ ] with me and i know your
address [ __ ]
uh so
someone hit my van while i was parked on
seventh street he didn't pay me i had to
pay for it all it's like four thousand
bucks
i have his address and his name if you
have any suggestions on what i could do
uh to get back at him i'm going to call
lawyers i need to do it soon it happened
in may i haven't done [ __ ] about it and
it's annoying
uh it's just like i need to take care of
myself by taking revenge on this guy uh
if i care about myself then i'll do that
um drop the addi
26
um
i
i love norm macdonald i'm sad that he
died i hope that he's
his legacy lives on and he's gonna be
famous in the future and everyone's
gonna love him more because they're
gonna figure it out where do i poop
inside of toilets most of the time if i
have to i poop inside my
my trash can
i haven't pooped in my trash can in
about a year or six months
usually i can find a public toilet to
squat in but if it's at night and i ate
a lot of like bad food then sometimes i
have to do it inside and
then i take it out right away because
you don't want to live with poop in your
van
um i'm not i'm doing reading and talking
uh
what turns me on about girls uh the
thing that turns me on the most about
girls is
that they have
the
physical
qualities that make a baby
and that they're pretty and that they're
hard to [ __ ]
have you any headband trash can not
really when do you plan on doing a
dallas show i just did a dallas show i
plan to be back january 15th so next
year
you should drive to central america
shouting run they're coming all the way
like paul revere
i'm gonna put some water on it i guess
that would help
uh
what do you think about god i don't
think god is real i think that god is a
helpful
helpful model to have just like uh you
know
like
a model of an atom
it's like a helpful thing to think about
if you need it
uh but i don't think it's
i don't think it's necessary uh i think
a lot of good people don't believe in
god what is wrong with your face it's
just how i am uh god is just like so
interesting
um
i like the way girls think girls think
differently than men and it's just
interesting
um girls are like more
they bring out different sides of you
and like uh women and men are supposed
to be together and then we're supposed
to complement each other with our
different energy styles and a man and a
woman together it's greater than the sum
of its parts we become a whole unit that
is capable of doing anything and i think
that's awesome unless you turn into yoko
ono and john lennon
in which case it's not as good
but john lennon was such a genius he
just needed an empty shell of a person
to latch on to and
he could continue to be himself
so that's all you need that's fine but
i'm looking for
someone who can complement my energy and
then we can
be complementing each other's energy and
do things awesome
how did you learn to talk in your sleep
i just did it i heard that i talk in my
sleep in korean
but lately i've been
uh taping my mouth shut when i sleep so
that way that i can have a dry mouth
and i wake up and it's
my mouth feels good and i breathe
through my nose the whole night so i
i do a lot of mouth taping at night
hopefully it doesn't [ __ ] up my lips
i don't want to get that plastic surgery
lit
um i'm a man i still don't admit he is
not gay either
um were you religious growing up or
always an atheist i was religious
growing up i believed in the
presbyterian korean jesus yes
and then i would pray i would go to
church all the time with my family and
then eventually i was like wait a minute
this isn't even real this is ridiculous
it's like god what is god like why do we
need it we have each other what is
really good about churches other people
and i think that we should all hang out
with each other more instead of
worshiping an imaginary person i mean if
you need it that's fine
but i think that we are all
our best friends i smoke weed yes i wish
i could smoke more weed but it hurts my
throat too much and it's [ __ ] my
throat up and i need it to talk and
breathe so i've stopped smoking weed as
much i will take edibles i will take
mushrooms and all that
um
yeah i mean i went to korean church and
it's just all koreans and it's just like
more of a community than
i think i think that's the best part of
it is that you get to learn
about other koreans just hang out and uh
you know commune with other koreans and
we have a strong community through
imagining this dude in the sky that's
loving us so if that's what it takes to
bring people together in a new country
and form communities then that's good
that's good
[Music]
i think that
it's a good excuse to gather around it's
hard to get people to gather around
every week if you're just like we're
korean and we should be hanging out more
but if you have a god then you're like
oh yeah let's hang out and worship god
together or something and then you can
hang out and make friends when you think
that you're worshiping god
what do you think of the state of
kentucky
i think they're backwards in a lot of
their practices and they're not a modern
state and that we should
make a better state
um i mean there's a
afterlife i think that afterlives exist
in other people like when i die there
will be a whole human race that
continues
um
so that's cool
and i don't need to be a part of it i
can just do my part right now and then
die and then i'll be happy with that
does tony use n word in his private time
no but i do i said the c word last time
and i didn't get demonetized so i'm kind
of getting drunk with power i don't know
how much i can [ __ ] get away with
what's the most dominant religion among
the korean community christianity
for some reason christianity really
stuck in korea i think it's our devotion
to america and our thanks for the korean
war we're like damn these people really
helped us out we should believe in their
god
uh
this guy said i'll figure it out huh
well i mean we all try to figure it out
i'm not just gonna be like
i'm not i don't know what i'm doing what
is the world i don't know what's going
on
i'm gonna try to
think that i have it figured out like we
shouldn't
be happy with not knowing we should try
to figure things out i mean there's a
lot of stuff i don't know but
the religion thing is pretty obvious i
mean it's just like a bunch of like uh
old people that had to believe something
so
i uh i don't know i just don't uh
religion has been hijacked a lot to be
used for purposes that are not ideal uh
religion is used to shove down your
throat ideas that are not uh logical but
are good for the group like monogamy or
like
abortion is bad
uh what do your parents think about what
you do in comedy i think that they think
that it's fine and that uh
it's a new world and they're progressive
and they're like not everyone's gonna be
doctor lawyers so maybe it's good that
he's doing something artistic
so you're pro cults as long as people
are being nice
yeah i mean if there's like a [ __ ]
excuse for you guys to all hang out and
it's like oh yeah totally i believe in
joshua fogg low toast
and like everyone's just like yeah we
love him but anyways we're going to the
slip and slide then i think it's awesome
like
whatever excuse you need
to uh
um
whatever excuse you need to uh gather
together and love your fellow humans if
you need a dude in the sky to tell you
that that's fine
um
[Music]
humans manifest evil without religion
history is full of examples yeah that's
true evil exists
it's not all religious based
but religion is not necessary and i
think we can go further without it i
think it's trapping us it's like what we
needed when we caveman to go into
society and have like a functioning
society but now that we're past
that
nascent stage of civilization we can let
go of all that religious [ __ ] and
just [ __ ] shoot to the moon
uh we don't need a man in the sky to
tell us not to murder each other
how are things with isabella is she
still pissed at you i don't know i still
look at her stories i'm still like
madly in love with her but she doesn't
uh want to be with me obviously she's in
england or something she's quarantining
somewhere so i'm guessing she's in a
country that takes coronavirus seriously
maybe asia maybe she's back in hong kong
but i know she was in england and uh she
was doing a lot of comedy there she
posted a lot of videos from there but i
haven't talked to isabella in a while
and i hope she's doing well and i uh i
really respect her as a comedian and as
a
person and as a very sexy sexy lady
um
sagan or feynman
i don't know they're both pretty cool
is this the famous van yeah
it brought more good than home overall
and prevented a lot of bad i mean it's
hard to tell but yeah i mean religion is
very necessary there's a reason why it
popped up in every civilization on earth
it's because it's a good way to wrap
everyone up and trap their subconscious
so that they're not doing crazy [ __ ] and
make a good civilization i mean there's
a reason why monogamy
exists it's because uh it's a good way
to structure society if you want to have
a bunch of hunter-gatherers combined and
turn them into agriculturalists make
them only [ __ ] one person but
i don't think we have to do that anymore
i think that's just what we did in the
past and that we should reject we should
it's like a rocket once they got past
the atmosphere the boosters fall away we
just need to let the boosters fall away
and just not have religion anymore
uh religion is fine if you want to do it
it's just like you can get so much
further without it there's a reason why
98 of scientists are not religious
there's a reason why
all the smartest people are on the
inventors and [ __ ] whatever they're
not religious it's just not necessary i
think
if category the basics of fundamental
facts of nature the pigs brought back
the crows to give them animal hope for a
better life after the farm
um i think that it's funny that uh
i think it's funny that uh
guns and 2a
uh i love guns and i love the second
amendment and i think it's cool that we
have guns i just don't know if it's
worth all the dead children but if you
think it is that's fine uh this is your
country and we can vote on it find out
how many people agree but i think like
the thing with guns is that it's not
that useful during a uh
takeover by the government because the
government has already taken us over and
we did nothing like guns are small arms
are useless
uh when it comes to uh
corporate takeovers like i would rather
us have power over corporations and the
power to unionize than guns i don't
think that's the most important power to
have
um i think our biggest powers with each
other and if we could organize and be
better than the sum of our parts
that's more powerful than guns and i'd
rather see that than everyone have a gun
but it is kind of cool that everyone has
a gun and that you have to respect the
individual and that's the cool thing
about texas i think is
that
um the cool thing about texas is that we
can uh
all have guns and people respect
personalities and individuals
uh
i think uh
i think that uh
people in texas have to respect each
other because anyone might have a gun so
if you have a gun
then
you have to respect them and that's kind
of cool that people in texas are just
like oh you're whatever
uh you're a person let me respect you
um
give me my f-15 brandon
um i think that uh
there's more to protecting
rights than guns
and that
we should do a lot more than just have
guns we should also [ __ ]
have a union and
fight and bargain collectively and stuff
um
korean ass jeeps
hey ask me anything i don't know
anything but i'll spout off and talk
about [ __ ] that i don't know about
because i want to
and i'm having fun
uh hopefully nothing happened
okay so i think that it's weird that uh
things are awesome and that i'm asian
oh my god i was doing the set at the
vulcan once and uh
i was just like spazzing out i was just
like bored and then i was like do you
guys think it's weird that i'm asian and
then the crowd was just like what
what are you doing jesus christ totally
joke you [ __ ] asian [ __ ]
fallacy
spouter
um comedians union it'd be nice to have
a union so you only want big guns
big government to have the guns
um yeah i mean that's how most countries
are in most countries only big
government have guns and they seem to be
doing fine like [ __ ] scandinavia or
like japan
uh
no one has guns there but they can still
bargain collectively and have like
a unified effort in trying to give
themselves rights and health care so i
think we should do that we should have
health care if you can use guns to get
us health care i'd love to see you do it
i'd love to see how that happens it'd be
interesting to see how but if you have a
hammer everything's a nail like if you
have a gun then you try to get
everything with a gun give me health
care and it's just weird um
why do you only encourage asians to
learn how to hunt try star perfecta why
don't you encourage everyone to hunt i
mean what is it about asians we have
smaller eyes so we can focus better on
the target
we're more studiously hunting
um i do love asians i think asians are
strong and that they are
a formidable race
um i think that
um
guns are cool but so is healthcare i'd
rather have healthcare than guns i wish
the second amendment was the right to
bear health care
and then i would support that
but if you can get us health care come
on gun nuts do something for society
rather than just bunker up and hide and
prepare to kill other people because you
actually are a misanthrope and you hate
people use your second amendment rights
to give us something
what have you given us besides freedom
from the british
um but that was after that was before
the second amendment came into
effect um
what have they done they um
they shoot children all the time with
their second amendment rights um i mean
they stop robbers and like people
threaten each other over parking spots
uh gangsters kill each other
but uh
yeah i mean uh universal healthcare
isn't the best but it's better than what
we have now we pay the most for health
care and we get the least out of it
in america i really need to cut my hair
um
i mean
i mean what do wouldn't you rather have
healthcare than guns
i uh
i should write that down guns in
healthcare
us up to world war i saved south korea
son thank you guyana spice for saving
south korea by splitting it in half
and
having a dictator
that kills our protesters and high
school and college students and uh
murders people
[Music]
um but yeah i mean i love america i just
think that we could do better and that
there is a responsibility to do better
um
i think that uh
i think that guns are fine you want gun
owners to take guns to fight for
something that is not all right have you
been to san bernardino
i think that uh
it's cool to
have guns
if you want guns
just do something with it you know
i've yet to see
something cool done with guns
for the people
um
yeah usa did split korea in half with
russia
i i think guns are very
dicey topic but i'm glad that we can
talk about it and uh you know what else
is going on
what else is going on in the news every
day i'm thankful i didn't kill a mod
arbory and i don't have to deal with
that legal headache it's like ah going
to sleep today without having murdered
anyone look at me living my best life
not having murdered people
can you imagine if you murdered someone
oh my god that'd be so annoying you'd
just be constantly thinking about that
person it's like what did i do
uh
yeah so i'm happy that i haven't
murdered anyone and so should you you
should be happy you haven't murdered
anyone too
that's a thing that you should be
thankful for
um
i don't need a president to be strong
person because i don't need a president
to tell me who i am i'm fine with an old
fart telling me what to do because uh
all he has to do is file paperwork like
i don't need him to be a strong person
why do you need
a strong person
like you need that
you need a strong president like really
like this guy's so far away why do you
need him to be strong
um
i don't need a mascot to feel good about
myself i don't need like a strong
wrestler you know it's it's not
important to me
so uh women uh they're very sexy
they have great ways of thinking
uh does pay for an abortion count as
murder for hire um yeah sure uh here's
my stance on abortion i think abortion
is awesome and we should do it more and
it doesn't matter if you think it's a
baby or not murder is necessary for life
to happen so yeah baby is a one cell is
a life okay and we we're gonna kill that
life murder is gonna happen you need
murder especially when it's a baby when
it's tiny like that it's easier to
murder and you should murder it if you
have to and then we can create a better
world like
people are such [ __ ] they don't want
to murder [ __ ] murder [ __ ] we murder
things all the time we should murder
more things
uh
yeah i mean strong president set a good
example for weak people maybe we should
have less weak people that look to the
[ __ ] oval office for an example for
what to do
you don't need an oval office you need a
dad that stays with you your whole life
because he hasn't murdered he wasn't
set in jail for seven years for having
an ounce of marijuana
uh
do you have a racial preference in girls
what about your parents well i don't
know what my parents racial preference
and girls are
i'm sure that they would love to have
sex with lots of different people
um no but i think they would want me to
marry a korean person so that they can
just be korean to her
but i'm not going to marry someone
because of how easily my parents can
communicate with them i'm going to marry
someone because i think they're a hot
sexy latina
uh
i think abortion you need you need to
kill babies you can't just have every
baby that pops in you should have babies
like when you want it and only when you
really really want it and if you don't
do that then people are going to be
devalued so
murder babies and then
you can have a great life
how to marry a north korean girl you
know everyone everyone likes a little
softie everyone wants to take care of
someone and like show them the ways this
is called cinnabon
this is how you eat it this is called a
fork here
open your mouth oh my god look how cute
she is she's eating cinnabon for the
first time i'd have so many great tech
talks
if i had a north korean girlfriend i
would just show her like basic [ __ ] like
this is called an electric toothbrush
oh my god look at her face when she used
an electric toothbrush for the first
time
um so
i think i'm i'm done for the night um
thank you i might come back later
tonight i never know um but i'll try to
do it tomorrow and then day after and
day after and day after
so thank you guys for tuning in i love